So what if I can’t see the Milky Way at
night, it’s just a little light pollution
right?
Hey there stars, Sapna here for DNews.
According to the Atlas of Artificial Night
Sky Brightness about 83% of humans on Earth
are exposed to night skies that are at least
10% brighter than natural levels, or what
the Atlas defines as “light pollution”.
When I say pollution you probably think of
smog or oil spills or some other substance
we put into the environment that really mucks
up the place.
By comparison then, calling an overabundance
of light “pollution” may sound a bit overdramatic.
What effect can leaving the light on all night
really have on the environment?
As it turns out our love of light can mess
with both flora and fauna more than you might
think.
Earth’s ecosystems have spent billions of
years adapting to a day-night cycle, but the
invention of artificial light and subsequent
vanquishing of the darkness is throwing some
organisms outta their groove in very profound
ways.
Take for instance baby sea turtles.
Those little guys hatch on the beach and it’s
imperative they get to the water before some
predator snatches them up.
When they’re born at night they find water
by putting the dark and elevated silhouette
of land behind them.
But lights from houses or roads along the
beach can disorient them, making them crawl
in the wrong direction until dawn when they’re
easy pickin’s.
That’s if they even get hatched in the first
place: momma turtles that have been returning
to the same beach for decades may be discouraged
by the brightly lit shore and look for another
nesting site, or they could get disoriented
themselves and wander into traffic.
Light pollution can effect some creatures
in the water also.
Microscopic animals called zooplankton hang
out at lower depths during the day and rise
up to feed on algae each night.
If the night sky is too bright, they don’t
rise up as high or in as great of numbers,
so they don’t eat as much algae, which can
in turn, contribute to an algal bloom.
Coastal light can also hurt some coral species
in the great barrier reef, which rely on phases
of the moon to sync their release of sperm
and eggs into the water.
If the moon’s phases are masked, then they
might not spawn at the right time and that
means less new coral.
Light pollution isn’t great news for some
land creatures either.
Birds that migrate at night are known to crash
into brightly lit towers or skyscrapers, or
circle them until they die of exhaustion.
Amphibians like salamanders that forage after
dusk will wait longer to come out since the
night sky is more brightly lit and they don’t
get as much food. and get this..
Some frog and toad males will not ribbit if
they’re well lit.. so then lady frogs won’t
holler back and mate with them.
But if you don’t care about the frogs or
the salamanders or the birds or the coral
or the baby turtles, well you’re heartless
but you should still know that light pollution
probably affects you too.
First off if you live in a big city like New
York City like I do...we can all say goodbye
to the stars, unless something knocks the
power out like an earthquake did to Los Angeles
in 1994.
Residents called Griffith Observatory asking
why the night sky looked different after the
earthquake.
They were seeing the Milky Way for the first
time.
If it’s bright enough to read a book outside
at midnight, that’s a sign those bright
lights can keep you up by stopping you from
producing melatonin.
Obviously that can cause sleep disorders,
but melatonin is also an antioxidant so it’s
possible that light is actually increasing
your risk of cancer as well.
And of course keeping those lights on requires
energy, and if that energy comes from a fossil
fuel source, light pollution is causing good
old-fashioned regular pollution too.
By leaving the light on all night you are
literally burning the midnight oil.
So if you can help it, stop leaving the light
on.
Light pollution can mess with your sleep,
but what can regular pollution do to the rest
of you?
Julia Covers that right here.
Have you noticed the effects of light pollution
in your life?
Let us know in the comments below, and don’t
forget to like and subscribe for more DNews
every day.